what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you guys are at it make sure you get a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt today if
you want the women to come up to you
left and right and just say how amazing
and awesome you are make sure you get a
t-shirt they are going to be delivered
at the end of the month
okay so our first story today um I talk
a lot about on this show how a lot of
times men will meet what they think is a
good woman and I've covered the story of
Tyrese Gibson getting divorced and he
has spoken about how he met his ex-wife
in a $15 sundress she signed the prenup
she was okay with everything and now she
is taking him to the cleaner in divorce
court and for months I've seen Tyrese
really asking on different shows where
he went wrong he wasn't Unfaithful he
loved his wife he really has no idea why
the marriage dissolved and this is how a
lot of men in their 40s and 50s hit the
red pill they they really think that
they have their life figured out they
have the woman that they love they're
good with it for the rest of their life
and then one day their woman comes home
and wants a divorce and they don't know
why and recently Samantha Lee is
actually giving some insight as to why
the couple did divorce let's pull it up
child's father have a lot of respect for
him I'll always there will always be a
part of me that will love him because of
like what we share together um in the
child that I look at every day like she
looks like him you know she looks like
us and like you know wow yeah yeah yeah
beautiful that is something are you now
in the spirit of potentially even being
able to rekindle a relationship like oh
my gosh
ask we going to Ed
it is that a hard question it is it's a
it's it's loaded because of the fact
that there's been so much that's
happened you know like there's been so
much that's occurred um
[Music]
okay it's my daughter's
father
so I would I would say this I would say
that if we were both going to show up
and we are both going to fight for it
equally and sacrifice equally
like you know things that I needed and
you know things that you know he needed
I wasn't perfect yeah um girl um so I
would I would say that if if if we were
both willing to fight and we were both
willing to do certain things and
yes something about that actually makes
me very happy no I don't know if that
makes you I don't know why no but I'm
just saying like if it's if it's it's my
child like you know no one wants a
broken family no no that's exactly
that's what it is for me yeah like if it
was something that it was like it was if
it was a situation you have to hear me
sir excuse me you have to hear me all
the way you have to hear me all the way
okay okay I'm
listening I want to point out that all
of the world's evil comes to
egalitarianism whenever you have a woman
that says we need to fight for this
relationship equally um there's two
places she went wrong not number one
once a guy is to the point that women
select him meaning he has his Fitness in
check he has his money in check he has
his game in check you know it takes men
a lot of work to get to the point to be
a guy that we want to marry and really I
would argue that women should put more
effort into the relationship than men I
think it works better that way men have
to focus on God on their purpose and
women are supposed to submit to the
authority of the man in their life
meaning a lot of times it seems to women
that they are doing more for the men
than the men are doing for them and it's
because they don't count the amount of
effort it has taken men to get to the
point where we want to select them and a
lot of times what what you'll see in
wives is they'll they'll think they're
doing more because maybe they're cooking
for their husband three days a week
maybe they're cleaning the house maybe
they're watching the kids but they don't
count the effort it took him to build
the life that you're in and my question
to her is what more effort could he put
in equally I mean he he's handsome he's
successful he's wealthy the grass is not
going to be greener on the other side I
don't know what this woman thinks is on
the other side as a 40-some year old
single mother and the problem is we have
romanticized divorce we have told women
that you are going to be happier on the
other side of divorce and it is just not
the case it's not true um occasionally
there are women that do Fair better
after divorce but over overwhelmingly
women are not more likely to remarry
they are not more likely to be more
financially stable they do not do better
unless they're stealing money from the
men and I think this is an important
lesson I think there's something we can
learn from this that a lot of times as
women we we we count favors and I always
say whenever you have a girl that says
we both need to invest in the into the
relationship I just did so much for him
I would argue that is actually the
biggest red flag because is your keeping
score and keeping score does not work in
relationships because true femininity is
actually selflessness it has nothing to
do with nails it has nothing to do with
fashion it has nothing to do with any of
that it's actually submitting and
serving the men in your life and that's
where a lot of these femininity coaches
get it wrong they focus on looking
feminine instead of being feminine and
the problem is you have a lot of wives
and mothers that might look the part but
they are not the part and and it's
really a phenomenon in society which I
call the pretend wives you know when we
think of our our mothers our
grandmothers or great-grandmothers the
last generation of real feminine
submissive women they weren't counting
all the stuff they did for you they
weren't saying I did this you need to do
that because true love is selfless but
this is my point is we have a lot of
women that are really fake wives they're
not actual submissive women but you know
they wear the sundress they have their
nails done they get the botox they look
pretty but in all actuality if you look
at the women 150 years ago they were not
concerned with looks but they were aund
times more feminine than the women today
I don't think the women weaving baskets
working on farms or any of the other
jobs that they did 150 years ago were
really concerned with the way that they
looked it came second their first needs
were the needs of their men and the
problem is the women today keep score so
they'll say say oh I did this for him I
did this for him I did this for him and
we don't keep track of the things that
they do for us because we're just
naturally kind of self-centered and we
think about everything from our point of
view instead of the view of the family
and as I've said really we have a bunch
of bronze and Below standard wives but
if you want to invest in gold not silver
or bronze if you're feeling unsure about
your finances you're not alone that's
why noble gold Investments is here to
help just here at straight from the
folks that they have helped the noble
gold crew walked me through everything
no stress and with their help I can
finally sleep easy at night now this
month Noble gold Investments is handing
out free 5 oce silver America the
Beautiful bullion coins if you qualify
for an IRA invest in gold and silver
with Noble gold Investments go to
noblegold investments.com now that's
Noble gold Investments the only gold
company that I trust if we can go back
and if I were able somehow to insulate
you with a pro marriage Pro relationship
Community do you think you still would
have actually gone through a divorce not
that time okay I don't know what would
have
happened oh I've never said this
publicly this what we do Harley
initiated exclusive baby make sure you
zoom in on this one okay it get actually
no I want to deny myself I want a
deniability um yeah no I I um
the the truth about the matter is that
if I had different people in my ear at
that time I would not have made that
decision no um and it's it's interesting
to see her Dodge accountability like the
plague you know what I mean her first
response is my friends made me do it and
I do appreciate her being honest I
really do but I also wanted to point out
how women it's like our first response
is to blame somebody else and not
ourselves um but I also wanted to point
out that women are very influenced by
the culture women are very influenced by
their friends women are very influenced
by their family women are influenced by
everybody around them and that is what I
see a lot of like tradcons I guess
they'll basically act like their women
are inept to the culture and it can
never happen to them and then time and
time again we see that it does for
example Dennis prager's been married
three times many public media
Conservative Christian personalities
have been married multiple times for
example Tom Brady you know and you ask
yourself were those men not Alpha enough
were they not did they not lead well
enough and that's why I point out that
men have a very real reason to fear
marriage I think it's a valid concern
and for some men it's just not going to
make sense so I'm going to look in the
comments section here they said fight
fight equally for something that she
ruined by by
herself yes
exactly exactly again it's a lack of
accountability well I had to divorce him
we didn't fight equally and you see the
simps co-signing this behavior and this
is the problem ladies these guys never
tell you the truth they are so deceptive
they are dishonest and Men hear the
things we say they process it and they
come to a conclusion if that makes sense
or it doesn't make sense
but most men will not tell you when it
doesn't make sense and you see her on
this podcast and and they're kind of
coddling her they're saying oh this
makes me happy instead of saying well
why did you ruin it it's always
everybody else and not themselves and
that's why I argue that really a lot of
these red pill channels Kevin Samuels
fresh and fit they're actually Heroes
because they tell women the truth and so
guys I always try to be honest with you
guys you know I never say that I have
lived my life perfect L I never say I'm
a saint I never say that you know I am
the epitome of the wife and mother that
you should look up to um but the problem
is we have a lot of tradcon women that
have been playing pretend they have been
pretending to be traditional for too
long and they walk like a duck they
quack like a duck but they do not talk
like a duck and I wanted to point out
videos that fake tradcon women really do
expose themselves let's pull this up the
black pill movement is a group of men
who have left the dating Market they
have deleted all dating apps they are no
longer asking women on dates and they
have no intention of ever getting
married I don't think many men actually
benefit from marriages or relationships
anymore in fact they strongly discourage
any romantic feelings towards the
opposite sex at all I actually empathize
with where radical feminism has rendered
men as a whole and in a quest to
rightfully take back your masculinity
I'm worried that you've hits your
trailer on the back of a movement that
is Bound for self-destruction and that
is the black pill movement or mgtow
which stands for men going their own way
just like women fall prey to the lies of
feminism that have entrapped us for
decades lies about abortion a career
first culture birth control men are just
as capable of falling for detrimental
lies and pursuit of doing the right
thing so if I'm hurting about something
let's say I'm starting to take the black
pill and I feel the negative emotions
what I'll do is gravitate towards a
community that validates my experience
and as I gravitate towards that
Community I feel better but then
sometimes what can happen is the
community itself can become toxic as
this starts to happen in a community it
actually worsens our mental health and
distorts reality even more we have a
common phrase for this now which is an
echo chamber every day regular
conservative men with good intentions
are falling for the smoke and mirrors of
black pillars who want you to believe
that your only only a true conservative
if you abstain from feelings
relationships and sex with women they
fail to see the value and the very thing
that true conservatism supports family
family family family I think that one of
the reasons feminism was so appealing to
women is not just because it offered
answers to various plights women face
but because it validated and unified
them the patriarchy they felt that they
lived in a society rigged against them
and for first wave feminism there was
some truth to this fortunately today men
and women coexist in a society where
they are legally equals there are no
exclusive rights for men that I do not
have access to still it's difficult to
dispute that men aren't under attack for
one women can freely hate men anywhere
in media Academia entertainment some of
you are like well not all men and of
course it's all men literally every
single one of them hate them hate them
hate them someone was like what about
your dad especially my dad I know it's
popular right now for female creators
and influencers to say that you know men
can function without women and that
they're so much better obviously I
disagree with the feminist point of view
that women are the better sex but my hot
take is what if both of those are
equally destructive because both genders
need and depend on the other to the
conservative women watching this I know
you're familiar with the concept of
taking a red pill the black pill
movement takes the idea of the red pill
even further where red pillars believe
that they've been awakened to perception
altering truths about the world around
them black pillars feel that they've had
a similar Awakening about women in
relationships they deeply resent how our
culture and the social environment have
become hostile to men let's talk about
some of the valid grievances the black
pill movement has take dating they say
that the me too and believe all women
movements have made it extremely
difficult for men to risk normal
flirtation or dating without having to
worry about having their lives ruined
Fair the blackpill movement paints a
picture of dating in the modern world
that is not so pleasant for men studies
suggest that there are as many as nine
men for every one woman on dating apps
research also finds that women are much
more selective than men on online dating
platforms okay so I wanted to show you
how it's almost like it like doesn't
compute when we don't like the
answers and she's really laying it out
she's saying right now you cannot
legally interact with women without a
consequence this is true there are
consequences for approaching women in
public there are consequences for
approaching women at the gym there's a
consequence for getting into a
relationship with a woman um where she
could potentially trap you with the kid
or she could also potentially put you on
child support alimony if if you have a
child she can come back 10 years later
and say that you raped her this is how
much power that women have and it's
interesting because instead of listening
to the Grievances of men and
understanding
them she she actually her default
reaction is to compare it to
feminism and her also default reaction
is actually not to take accountability
as women notice how women always blame
the culture they never blame women and
if you blame women you become the bad
guy you become evil and then you get
accused of being just as bad as the
feminist but women are in control of the
culture
the media caters to women the laws cater
to women so who is responsible for the
destruction of society women some argue
that men shouldn't have given them that
power and you could argue that but the
truth is the majority of women have
participated in the culture where the
majority of men did not participate in
making those laws that was not their
choice so again there's more
responsibility that falls on the women
the other thing that I noticed is she
still defaults to egalitarianism I I
don't actually know if she's a Christian
she just kind of gives the that vibe
from the video I don't I don't know much
about her but if you really are a true
Christian you are supposed to believe in
patriarchy you are supposed to believe
in a natural order of the world the
natural order of the world is God men
women children women are supposed to
submit to the authority of men women are
supposed to be the weaker vessel why
would you submit to the authority of
someone that is not smarter Than
You Yes Yes Men by and large are
significantly smarter and more competent
than women we are not equal we are not
even close to the same and it's
interesting because she still defaults
to egalitarianism you know and I want to
tell you a story um so I've been working
on a divorce documentary for over a year
and I I've done many interviews in that
divorce documentary and I'm sorry but
good traditional men get punished in
this Society it is absolutely a logical
conclusion to come to to not want to
deal with women because it's more hassle
than it's worth I'm going to give you
guys a stat if a woman slept with more
than between three to five Partners she
only has a 25% chance of a happy
marriage doing a business deal with a
25% chance of success you would never do
yet only 4% of women wait till they're
married to have sex so knowing this
information knowing that body counts are
through the room Pro why on Earth would
you encourage men to sign up for that
and on top of that what you'll see and I
don't know if she does this but a lot of
these tradcon women also shame men for
wanting to date younger women they call
them creepy they call them weirdos for
wanting to date younger women when
really it's just older women trying to
compete and the truth of the matter is
that for most women over the age of 25
they're done they will not have happy
marriages they will not be submissive
wives and they are too stuck in their
ways really the the only solution I see
is the next generation of women learning
from the older generation of women and
doing better and moving forward but the
way it is now I don't see it as a viable
option for men and regardless of what I
say regardless of how much you see these
tradcon women saying no no don't leave
the relationships and marriage don't do
it please don't do it please no no no we
need to find someone to marry us
regardless of what I say this is the
direction it's going men naturally weigh
the risks and rewards and right now the
risks outweigh the rewards regardless of
what I say men will naturally do that
and it's so interesting that women think
that they are more logical than men they
think that the conclusion that roughly
60% of men under 30 have come to which
is nope don't need marriage don't need
relationships is illogical and they know
better instead of asking themselves why
is this large group of men coming to
this conclusion you know I always say
you cannot build a big male audience
without saying something that is true
you you can build a big female audience
spewing [__] but you cannot build a
big male audience men are not easily
fooled the way that women are easily
fooled okay so there was a video going
viral on Twitter and so many people were
weighing in of a woman being interviewed
on the street street saying she wants a
minimum of $200 for a dinner let's pull
it up I feel like if I'm going to get
ready and I'm going to use all my
products to come out with you I need
like a minimum of $200 a minimum that's
like being nice and what does the man
get in return for that my
presents what aren't you having his
presentence within you already I hear
you but no no I mean like I'm here to
get to know you I'm here to get to know
you you invited me out but he has to
drop $200 yeah because minimum yeah just
because just cuz you have to do your
makeup um because I have
to okay so we're going to do the math my
my moisturizer is $400 my eye cream is
$300 my Serum is like another $300 my
makeup you know not included so if I
have to spend you know that's my money
I'm spending my money on these products
I'm going to use these products what are
you using them for though for myself
okay but I'm going to use these products
and I'm going to show up because it's
not like I'm going to show up in sweats
the man doesn't owe you anything if
you're just getting to know each other
if you're inviting me out you owe me a
DAT okay so I I have a couple questions
when I hear this one why is her presence
more valuable than his presence yes
women put money and time and effort into
their looks men put time and effort into
building a career getting into good
shape they they put in hundreds of hours
to become the person that women want to
go on dates with so my question to her
is why is your
time more valuable than his and I
actually agree with the interviewer
where I think in the beginning money
doesn't matter I know we're in 2023 a
lot of women expect that most most men
aren't even too fussy about it but to me
her attitude is the problem it is
entitlement and if she feels entitled to
your money now what is going to change
in 10 years when she takes you to family
court and the other thing that people
don't realize is chivalry is actually
gynocentric so what is gynocentrism
gynocentrism messes up the natural order
of the world I am Catholic I believe the
natural order of the world goes God men
women children I believe women are most
happy when they are serving the men and
what chivalry did is actually it started
with proposals so men used to kneel to
Kings and and that goes with the natural
order of the world weaker men would
submit to Stronger men okay so what they
did was they replaced the stronger man
with a woman that's gynocentric it's
putting the men below the women that is
gynocentrism and that is why we have all
of the problems we have today it's not
just from a hundred years ago it's not
200 years ago this goes back a thousand
years um so what she's asking for is
she's saying do all this for me plan the
date do all this for me and serve me
when really I I believe relationships
work when the women serve the men that
is the best strategy um so let's pull up
the next clip it's a black dude with a
microphone walking around Miami and he's
saying to a girl hey girl what's the
minimum a man should spend on the first
date and she's like well I used all my
products I got ready I did my makeup I
don't know 200
bucks and everyone's clowning this chick
and clown world shared it and I agree
with 99% of what clown World say I think
I follow them they follow me we share
each other's stuff but I actually don't
think that woman did anything wrong I
don't think that woman said anything
wrong she's not grossly obese she's not
overtly ugly she's not overtly
unattractive she seems like a relatively
attractive woman she doesn't seem
outlandish or insane or wild in her ways
she's she's dressed very nicely she's
obviously put a lot of time into her
preparation you know it's not so much
about $200 being a set figure but let me
tell you something women deserve effort
when you take them on dates and when you
take women places they do deserve effort
because as much as I look amazing
tonight in my saval row tailored suit
with my Rolex watch on my alligator
shoes my thinning hair but still average
average hair up iage for hair as as good
as I look it took me about 4 minutes
from getting out of the shower to get
ready hair gel shirt jacket pants shoes
watch done that's it you know men should
always pay for dates one never
50/50 because the man is always the one
asking the woman out you as a young man
going on a date are trying to get a
woman usually to give up the most sacred
thing that she has you if you're going
out to date on a woman no matter how
honest you are you can be a good
Christian man in which case you're
looking for more you want her hand in
marriage eventually you want her to Bear
your children that's what a first day is
it is an interview for the most
important thing a woman could possibly
give you she is interviewing you and you
have asked for that opportunity to think
$200 is too much and that's obscene and
insane for a woman to want to go out on
a date where maybe the dinner's kind of
nice she has a few glasses of wine after
the 3 hours she's put in getting ready
shaving her legs all the [__] that women
do I wanted to point out a couple things
I've noticed with the tape Brothers a
lot of times they'll give speeches and
they're still a bit gynocentric so what
is gynocentric it's always the woman is
on the pedestal the woman is above a man
I I wouldn't say simp um I can't imagine
that a guy with that much wealth status
Etc simps but I will say that his speech
is a little bit out of touch
and he really mischaracterized what she
said he said oh she was just asked with
a microphone and she's like yeah well
$200 no no no she said $200 is being
nice and the truth of the matter is most
women will marry average men maybe she
will get a slightly above average guy
but it puts Tristan in a good situation
because he can say hey $200 that's
nothing just pay for dinner well that's
easy to say when you're
a multi-billionaire and the truth of the
matter is inflation is through the roof
there are average men in this country
that do important infrastructure jobs
and I really don't like this idea that
if a guy is Frugal with his money that
he then should not date he does not
deserve a woman um it used to be that
men that had good jobs and were working
could get a wife and kids and that is
not the case in 2023 for example 45% of
men do infrastructure jobs that means
they drive the trucks they pave the
roads they build the buildings they do
the hard jobs in society a lot of these
men are average earners let's say he
wants to get a girlfriend right let's
say he goes on a date with four women in
a month trying to find a girlfriend or
takes her on four dates that's $1,000 a
month that is not feasible for the
average man and a lot of times what I
see with these influencers is they just
get overwhelmingly out of touch and I I
don't know why he's misar iing what she
says the the next thing is he talks
about she takes four minutes to get
ready well Tristan it it takes the guy
10 years to get ready to be at a point
where women want to go on dates with him
and that's why that's why I argue that
chivalry is putting a woman on a
pedestal because it's saying the man
should still do for the woman when
really the natural order of the world is
the woman submitting to the man and
doing for the man again the natural
order of the world is God men women
children women only truly love when they
are doing the most for a guy when they
are serving a man so it's interesting
because feminists have asked for equal
treatment for decades yet when it is
given to them they cry about it so there
is a video talking about how men should
never hit women let's pull it up cuz men
should never hit a woman why
not that's just up what why why should a
man hit a woman to protect
himself oh man this isn't this is a lot
what you I just disagree with your
viewpoints why that you you think a man
should hit a woman should a woman hit a
yes I do I don't think violence is the
answer to anything no in protection he's
self-defense let's say a woman he
shouldn't just go around hindering just
for no reason yeah but let's say that
should women hit men no right so if a
woman should hit a man shouldn't you
smack her back no why not cuz she's a
girl well she doesn't know
that uh but I just think that's unfair
so if a woman smack a man what should he
do he probably deserved it to be honest
what yeah you want to play this game
let's go and doesn't she deserve to be
smacked back if she no she's a girl girl
guys should not hit girls but girls
should hit guys I never said that no but
if they do the guy should smack them at
no why not cuz guys shouldn't hit girls
why cuz it's it's just that's that's
just unfair well how because girls are
tender and and beautiful creatures that
should not be hit but don't they know
that before they hit the man that they
can't handle it I don't know it's
interesting how whenever women do
something wrong it's like the default
blame men well he probably deserved it
did he for what women are tender and
Beautiful Creatures are they they're
more likely to kill infants than the
elderly and you know what's interesting
whenever I try to find something that
women are better at I've just noticed
it's always something that can't be
measured that's like an intangible I I
never get an actual anyways um you know
feminists ask for equality here you go
equal rights equal lefts baby and I
actually agree I I think if a woman hits
a man girl you you're going to get your
[__] rocked I I I didn't tell you to do
that I don't I don't hit men I don't do
that so if you choose to do that then
don't come crying to me when you get a
black eye when you get your when you get
you know all all beat up and you're
going to keep seeing cases in the news
where you see these you know these guys
die because they were told they can
never hit back you know it's interesting
because a lot of abusive women blame the
abuse on the men when really a lot of
times um they were protecting themselves
and I found this out actually when I
started doing
shows um my default was always just to
believe people you know what I mean like
when someone gives you a story of
something traumatic that they went
through your your gut reaction isn't to
say I don't believe you or ask them all
these questions but one day a girl was
talking and someone in the comment said
ask her if she filed a police
report and the answer was no and I said
okay tell me specifically what happened
and you know the more of the story
unraveled The more she said everything
um you know one one girl told
me that her ex pushed her like down or
like shoved her on the ground something
like that and it turns out that she was
trespassing this woman wouldn't leave
this man's house and then was mad that
he kicked her out I mean how else was he
supposed to get you to leave and and
this is the problem is that women are
told we can do virtually whatever we
want with no consequences you are
amazing you are gold but really today
women are pretty much worthless so if
you want to take control of your
financial future and you don't know
where to start Noble gold Investments
understands living in Precious medals
may sound confusing but the team at
Noble gold makes it easy let's hear from
actual Noble gold customers the staff
answered all of my questions and helped
me every step of the way no pressure
sales tactics just honest guidance
securing my future is less stressful
thanks to Noble Gold's expertise so
don't settle for financial uncertainty
they'll suggest options and see if you
can diversify into gold and silver right
now Noble gold Investments is offering a
free 5 ounce silver America the
Beautiful bullion coin for qualified
accounts don't settle for financial
uncertainty Noble gold Investments has
an A+ rating with a better business Peru
and countless five-star reviews why wait
go to Noble goldinvest docomo gold
investments.com the only gold company I
trust okay so plus-size model Abby Bible
showcased her sexy date night outfit
let's pull it up so plus-size model Abby
Bible known for her confidence and style
recently wowed her 60,000 Instagram
followers with a a sexy date night
outfit she dawned a backless cutout crop
top that exposed Ed her back and
cleavage flaunting her size 22
figure her fans praised her for the
stunning look showcasing herself
self-proclaimed Unapologetic fat girl
attitude in a series of alluring photos
she confidently posed and even revealed
a tattoo oh a tattoo on her chest oh a
chest tattoo let's let's
see wow no the back
flabs I don't understand why can't you
just wear flowy dress like the rest of
the fat chicks why do you
oh why do they why do they cheer this on
this is so sad this is oh God the
blubber I don't want to see it
anymore put that away put that can we
please stop
don't guys why do women lead each other
to destruction you don't look good chica
it's time to get on the treadmill start
running please put it away please please
please wear a flowy outfit and please
stop making me cover this
because I I just read the news here the
body positive people actually I would
argue are body negative because they
only praise bodies that are unhealthy
where is the praise for healthy bodies
and I'm talking actual healthy bodies
not women that claim they have thyroid
issues and are 300 bajillion pounds um
but the actual thin in shape health
looking chicks and the truth
is that you will only find them
glorifying obesity so let me know what
you guys want me to cover next time on
Pearl daily make sure you like the video
on your way out and subscribe and get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
today I will talk to you guys next
time